2022 is shaping up to be a heck of a year
for the world of superheroes — and with
vampire movies, legal sitcoms, holiday specials,
and plenty of multiverse madness, this is
Marvel like you've never seen before.
Which project are you looking forward to the
most?
Although Spider-Man has been on loan to the
MCU for several years, the web-slinger is
still officially owned by Sony Pictures — as
are his many supporting characters.
So while Peter Parker has been swinging around
the MCU, Sony has been working on their own
interlocking cinematic universe of Spider-Man
characters, kicking off with 2018's Venom.
"Well, you know, I aim to please."
Joining Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock in the Sony
Spider-verse will be Morbius, based on the
"living vampire" who first appeared in the
pages of Marvel comics in 1971.
Morbius will star Jared Leto as Dr. Michael
Morbius — a brilliant biochemist whose attempts
to cure his own fatal blood disease go predictably
awry, transforming him into a superpowered
ghoul who must consume human blood to survive.
Joining Leto in the film will be Adria Arjona
as Martine, the female lead of the film, while
Doctor Who star Matt Smith will be serving
as the main antagonist, Loxias Crown.
Also appearing in Morbius will be Michael
Keaton, most likely reprising his role as
Adrian Toomes from Spider-Man: Homecoming,
which would make Morbius the first full crossover
between the MCU and Sony's Spidey films.
Daniel Espinosa will direct from a script
by Lost in Space co-creators Matt Sazama and
Burk Sharpless.
Morbius will hit theaters on January 28, 2022.
The sequel to 2016's Doctor Strange has been
in development since before that flick even
hit theaters, and in 2019 it was revealed
that the sequel will be titled Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness.
The movie will co-star Elizabeth Olsen as
Wanda Maximoff, appearing hot off the heels
of WandaVision.
Most of the previous movie's cast will be
returning, joined by Xochitl Gomez, who will
be playing the dimension-hopping superhero
America Chavez.
Otherwise known as Miss America, Chavez is
notable for being one of Marvel's most well-known
LBGTQ+ characters.
The creative team for the second Strange film
changed in two big ways during production.
Firstly, Evil Dead and Spider-Man director
Sam Raimi stepped in for original director
Scott Derrickson when Derrickson departed
the project due to creative differences with
Marvel.
Raimi will also be reuniting with composer
Danny Elfman, who's taking over scoring duties
from Doctor Strange composer Michael Giacchino.
Considering the MCU is revisiting Raimi's
Spider-Man movies as part of Spider-Man: No
Way Home, it really does feel like Raimi was
destined to return to the Marvel universe.
The multiverse goes mad on May 6th, 2022.
Given his fantastic character arc over his
last several appearances, nobody was particularly
surprised to hear that Thor would be the first
Avenger to receive a fourth solo film.
Thor: Ragnarok's Taika Waititi will be returning
to direct Thor: Love and Thunder, which will
also see the return of Natalie Portman's Jane
Foster.
Apparently, Foster will follow in her character's
recent comic book footsteps by picking up
Mjolnir to become Thor herself.
Returning Thor stalwarts include Jaimie Alexander
as Lady Sif and Tessa Thompson as Valkyrie,
while Chris Pratt will also be joining the
cast as Star-Lord.
Meanwhile, basically every other Guardian
has also been spotted on-set in Australia,
making the whole team's involvement more or
less a dead certainty.
Serving as the antagonist for Love and Thunder
will be Christian Bale as Gorr the God Butcher,
a character who, in the comics, is obsessed
with killing gods and absorbing their power.
A number of other A-listers are set to appear,
including Matt Damon, Sam Neill, and Luke
Hemsworth, who you may recall playing “Thor”
opposite Damon’s “Loki” in Ragnarok.
This time, they'll be joined by Melissa McCarthy,
who will be playing yet another Asgardian
actor.
Russell Crowe is also set to star as the Greek
god Zeus.
How will this all come together?
Well, that's anyone's guess.
But we'll know for sure when Thor: Love and
Thunder hits theaters on July 8th, 2022.
Despite raking in billions of dollars among
them, none of the live-action Spider-Man films
managed to do what Into the Spider-Verse did:
score an Academy Award.
The Best Animated Feature of 2018 is considered
by some to be among the greatest superhero
films ever made, with a supremely innovative
animation style and a novel focus on its eclectic
cast of alternate-universe Spider-People.
Spider-Verse was so singular a cinematic achievement
that it seems like its success would be impossible
to duplicate — but that's not going to stop
Sony from trying.
The Spider-Verse sequel will center on the
burgeoning romantic relationship between Miles
Morales and Gwen Stacy.
In 2019, it was also reported that the film
will take place two years after the events
of the first film.
Additional plot details are still a mystery,
but a teaser shared by the official Spider-Verse
Twitter account features 17 different spider
logos, indicating that, once again, a variety
of Spider-People will arrive from across the
multiverse.
"This could literally not get any weirder.”
This would be in keeping with what Sony Pictures'
Amy Pascal said when she told Vanity Fair
that Into the Spider-Verse 2 will feature
more female versions of Spidey.
On that note, it has also been revealed that
Issa Rae will be joining the cast as Jessica
Drew — better known as Spider-Woman.
Expect to see yet more versions of the web-slinger
when Into the Spider-Verse 2 arrives on October
7th, 2022.
After the tremendous success of 2018's Black
Panther, a sequel seemed like a foregone conclusion.
Sure enough, in the fall of 2018, The Hollywood
Reporter announced that Black Panther 2 was
officially happening, with original writer-director
Ryan Coogler returning to write and direct.
Chadwick Boseman was also expected to reprise
his role as T'Challa.
Tragically, in August 2020, Boseman passed
away following a four-year struggle with cancer.
The news came as a shock to Boseman's fans
and colleagues alike, as the actor had kept
his condition and treatment quiet, even as
he continued to work.
While Marvel declined to comment on the future
of Black Panther immediately following Boseman's
death, Black Panther: Wakanda Forever is now
confirmed to be moving forward, with a release
date of November 11th, 2022.
Executive producer Victoria Alonso has confirmed
that Wakanda Forever will not be using a digital
double to stand in for Boseman, leading many
to speculate that someone else will take up
the mantle of Black Panther.
Much of the first movie's cast will be returning,
joined by Marvel newcomer Tenoch Huerta, who
will be playing one of the film's antagonists,
as well as Michaela Coel in an undisclosed
role.
Additionally, Wakanda Forever will serve as
the introduction to the character of Riri
Williams, played by Dominique Thorne, who
will later be headlining her own Disney+ series.
Although further details for Wakanda Forever
are still scarce, there can be little doubt
that the sequel's story and its characters
will find an appropriate and satisfying way
to honor their king.
While most of Marvel's Disney+ shows seem
to exist to help further the overarching plot
of Phase Four and beyond, one title doesn't
seem all that interested in epic crossovers
or sprawling narratives.
That's right — The Guardians of the Galaxy
Holiday Special is coming to Disney+ in 2022.
"Welcome to the frickin' Guardians of the
Galaxy."
So what can fans expect from a holiday-themed
MCU special?
One may need to look no further than the much-maligned
Star Wars Holiday Special, which Guardians
writer and director James Gunn says he "unironically
loved" as a kid.
Gunn has said in the past that he's had an
idea for a Guardians holiday special for years,
adding that it's one of his favorite stories
ever.
While he hasn't offered up any clues about
what this story actually looks like, Gunn
has assured fans that The Guardians of the
Galaxy Holiday Special will be crazy and fun;
he has also clarified that it will be live-action
and will bring back all of the main Guardians
cast.
Gunn also confirmed that the special will
be considered MCU canon, being set between
Thor: Love and Thunder and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 3.
Further, Gunn has claimed in a tweet that
the special will introduce someone who, in
his opinion, is one of the greatest MCU characters
of all time" — although who that could be
is anyone's guess.
All shall be revealed, however, in late 2022.
She-Hulk is based on the character of the
same name, who was first introduced in the
comics in 1980.
In the comic book universe, Jennifer Walters
is a promising young attorney who is shot
and wounded by a vengeful mobster.
To save her life, she receives a blood transfusion
from the only match available: her cousin,
Bruce Banner.
His gamma-irradiated blood has a predictable
effect, but as She-Hulk, Walters retains her
personality and lawyerly intellect.
The series pilot will be directed by Kat Coiro,
who will also direct several other episodes
and serve as executive producer.
Jessica Gao, best known for her work on Rick
and Morty, will be heading up the writers
room.
Jennifer Walters will be played by Orphan
Black star Tatiana Maslany, joined by Mark
Ruffalo, who is reprising his role as Bruce
Banner.
Also featured is Tim Roth, who returns as
the villainous Abomination.
That character debuted in The Incredible Hulk
before making a cameo appearance in Shang-Chi
a full 13 years later.
Meanwhile, The Good Place star Jameela Jamil
will be starring as the villainous Titania,
while Ginger Gonzaga is set to play Jennifer's
best friend.
Expect to see this new Marvel series hit Disney+
in 2022.
Marvel's first Muslim superhero will be getting
a spotlight on Disney+ with the upcoming series
Ms. Marvel.
Fans were delighted when news about the show
broke in 2019, as Kamala Khan's adventures
have been hugely popular ever since her introduction
in 2013.
Portraying the teen superhero will be newcomer
Iman Vellani, who, before this, was known
for her work as part of the Next Wave Committee
at the 2019 Toronto Film Festival.
Referring to Kamala's ability to change the
shape and size of her body, the character's
creator G. Willow Wilson told Polygon:
"She's got very comic booky powers.
God bless them trying to bring that to live
action; I don't know how that's going to work
out in a way that doesn't look really creepy."
Joining Vellani in Ms. Marvel will be The
Walking Dead's Matt Lintz as Kamala's best
friend, Bruno Carrelli, as well as relative
Hollywood newcomer Laurel Marsden as Kamala's
best frenemy, Zoe Zimmer.
Ms. Marvel is set to premiere on Disney+ in
summer 2022.
Marvel fans have been waiting for years to
see Moon Knight make his on-screen debut,
and now it's finally happening.
Helmed by Egyptian filmmaker Mohamed Diab,
along with indie filmmaking team Justin Benson
and Aaron Moorhead, Moon Knight will follow
Marc Spector, a former Marine and mercenary
who is left for dead on a covert mission in
Egypt.
He is then spared and healed by the Egyptian
god Khonshu — in exchange for Spector becoming
his earthly avatar of justice.
Considered by some to be Marvel's answer to
Batman, there's one distinct facet of the
character that sets Moon Knight apart from
DC's Dark Knight: his struggle with Dissociative
Identity Disorder.
Moon Knight employs a number of his multiple
personalities to assist him in his crime-fighting
activities, and recent comic runs have even
suggested that his powers might not be real
at all.
Oscar Isaac will be stepping into the role
of Marc Spector for Moon Knight, fresh off
his three-film stint as Poe Dameron in the
Star Wars sequels and a stunning turn as Leto
Atreides in Dune.
Joining Isaac in undisclosed roles will be
Ramy star May Calamawy and Oscar-nominated
actor Ethan Hawke.
Speaking to The Wrap about his work on Moon
Knight, Hawke said:
"With Moon Knight, people don't know much
about it.
It doesn't have a lot of baggage.
Oscar [Isaac] is giving an absolutely phenomenal
performance, and it feels exciting to be a
part of it with him."
We'll learn just how Hawke fits into the world
of Moon Knight when the series hits Disney+
sometime in 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.